hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on monster on a world
again and today we're gonna be doing
another solo guide and this one's going
to be on a shore Rathalos I should have
done this a long time ago but I only
thought about doing the monsters for the
more difficult ones such as Newark agon
TT Ostra the other dragons but I thought
just because I'm having it I didn't have
a difficulty with a specific monster
doesn't mean somebody else out there
isn't so I'm going to be going back and
doing every single Monster Monster on a
world yes that even includes Great
Jagger's and doing a guide on them on
how to defeat them solo as normal with
this we're gonna be talking about the
physiology report then going into the
recommended loadout the moveset and then
some tips for the surrounding area and
some general tips on the monster so that
guys like the video if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new I covered the
solo guides and all this stuff for every
monster Monster Hunter world as well as
tips and tricks to make everybody a
better Monster Hunter player and I
covered the event quest that pop up
weekly so I let you know which ones are
the most important and how to do them
efficiently and what the rewards you get
from them so that guys let's get started
so as I stated we're gonna be doing
Azrael rathalos since because he's
currently in an event quest at the time
I'm recording this would get you better
rewards with bonus HR and it's always a
good thing
let us start going off with the
physiology report asura restless weak
points are head wings and tail with the
head wings tail and chest being
breakable and/or severable he's the most
weakest in the head compared to the
other parts of his body so definitely
try to aim for that as much as possible
or his weaknesses his weakest element is
dragon and for his ailments it's a
three-way tie between sleep paralysis
and stun so definitely use one of those
four options to maximize the amount of
damage you do before the recommended
loadout I recommend you use a vitality
mantis you can negate some damage
against him as well as using flash pods
and antidote slash herbal medicines
whatever you prefer because as you're a
rat looks kind of like poison which
we'll get into in a little bit honest of
bringing flash pods because Azeroth
loves to fly in the air a lot more than
being on the ground so this will
basically cut the time in the fight
almost in half by doing this and then
lastly of course being the essentials
like mega and max potions as well as any
buffs that you might like like mega
seeds demon drugs anything like that
that you might have that's entirely up
to you though and now that that's over
let's get into his moveset so his first
move is this quick fireball attack which
is very different from a normal fireball
attack which we'll get into in a little
bit usually after he roars
he will go into the air a little bit and
then do a fireball hit like this on
screen best course of action is to stay
to the sides of him when you fight him
first when you first start stay far away
from him or if you're high enough level
use the rock steady mantle to negate his
roar if you are hit by this movement
stay still and do not touch your
controller because you will stay on the
ground and not get hit because the
iframes you have on the floor because
right after he will most likely do one
to two swooping attacks and try to claw
you if you get up too early so just from
if you happen to get hit by this just
stay on the floor and just sit there
next move is his tail swipe this move
and flex poison when hit by it so
definitely watch out for that you can
tell when he's prepping this move
because he looks like he's looking at
his tail from behind simply dodging in
or away from him works or if you're
nervous you can do the sprint jump like
I did in the clip either way it works
completely fine another move is the
normal fireball attack I like to call
very similar to the one we talked about
before you can easily dodge roll this by
rolling out of the way of the attack
like I said it's very similar to the
other one except this is just he shoots
it instead of getting into the air and
shooting it right below him he also has
another fire move and this is the fire
spray attack where he does a simple
spray of fire in front of him
dodge rolling will work to avoid this
move as well as being out of range this
move will catch you on fire if you're
not too careful so definitely be aware
of that and then for the last move is a
quick ground-pound after going into the
air he can also pound the ground with
his claws to do some quick damage
against you once he enters the air dodge
roll away or simply sprint away as quick
as possible to evade this and the other
move that we talked about previously
that's it for his moveset he has a
pretty limited move set but they are
somewhat decently damaging especially if
you are fighting a temperate version of
him but regarding the areas and tips use
flash pods when he's airborne to
maximize the amount of efficiency out of
them dodge roll three times to get rid
of the fire on your character if you
happen to be hit by those attacks and if
you're fighting Azarath of us in the
ancient forest which most of the time
you usually are you can use the vine
traps para toads in flash bugs depending
on the area in which you are in to
really control the fight usually where
he likes to go to sleep or where he
starts in the beginning there is usually
flash bugs around there as well whether
they be on the trees and you collect
them and craft them into flash pods or
there's just flash like little bubbles
that you can just smack with your knife
and they will basically do the same
thing you normally don't fight him
outside but on the outside more to the
left of the map there are para toads in
there so if you try to lure him in there
on these small chances
on the ground those can do some
paralysis damage as well as always if
there's anything I missed or you think
that would be helpful that I didn't
mention put in the comments below so
your fellow hunters can be caught up
with all the info on Azure Rathalos I
mean that guys that's going to be the
end of the video today guys hopefully
you guys did enjoy this guide like I
said I'm gonna be doing the guides for
all the monsters since I kind of did a
disservice by not doing this earlier so
do apologize for that I'm gonna be
getting on track and start uploading
these a lot more frequently as I do the
monsters and go back and fight them but
as always thank you guys for sticking
around the video like the VP to enjoy it
really has helped me out subscriber for
new I covered the solo guides for every
monster Monster Hunter world as I've
stated previously the event quest I do
weekly so I keep so everyone goes up the
date on what to do with the event and
quest how to do them and how to do them
you know efficiently and stuff like that
as well as tips and tricks to make
everybody a better Monster Hunter player
my two most recent videos will be on
screen if you guys want to check that
out and with that guys hope every
yesterday and peace out thanks for
watching the video